I really can't even imagine the pressure
of jumping into something like x-men
when you're going into something that
big especially for the very first time
is it a no-brainer to want to take this
potentially game-changing opportunity or
are you sitting there and kind of
weighing the value of the pressure of
being associated with a really popular
brand you I think try and always weigh
up each each job in character and what
you're going into with the same kind of
assessment I suppose going in and what
the character is who's directing or
who's producing who's making the film
and and what the story is and what the
character is if it's something that you
can feel you can bring something to and
have a have an angle on but they're know
so yeah there's definitely I suppose
from my standpoint if there's if it is a
big franchise like that I mean it's
different because I you know with x-men
I'm playing a supporting role and then
that's actually a lot of weight lifted
from you going into those things because
it's not riding on your back you're
getting to be a part of something that's
a lot bigger than you and that's where
it's actually very freeing so I really
thrive and enjoy that that idea but yeah
definitely
in in the past and when you get offered
kind of those bigger tentpole movies
that maybe is relying more on you as a
lead character that is something you
have to kind of look at in a different
way because like I was saying earlier it
is a business so people kind of do judge
you on how those films perform more so
than if you go and do an indie film that
doesn't work out and people don't
particularly see so it is it is a
different assessment I suppose from from
your angle always got to look at it from
a creative standpoint first but there
are different kind of things that play I
suppose with that has the x-men
experience kind of changed your opinion
on signing on for future franchises
because I know this was completely out
of your control but you and you made
such a big him even though it is an
ensemble series you made such an
impression on that franchise and what
happened to it was entirely out of your
control so does that kind of put a bug
in your head when the next thing comes
knocking on you
door for like a multi film deal where
you know you got to commit no matter
what the industry and the future for the
industry holds
it's tricky those are the any multi
lengths sort of deal is interesting to
sign onto because it can shape your
future quite a lot and also it's an odd
thing because yeah as you say you don't
always have complete control over it the
only thing that you can rely on is that
hopefully if something's good and people
like it then it keeps going and that
means that you'll obviously want to keep
being involved with it and it would the
x-men experience I had they have made so
many brilliant friends and had such a
great time making them and and love all
the people involved so so we're
certainly it's not some yeah if those
sorts of things came about again works
and multi deal whatever it's not
something that I would be intimidated by
under the right circumstances